the number i want to talk about is 6174
and it doesn't seem to have anything
which is unusual about it
but caprica showed that if you carry out
a procedure which i'll
outline for you it always comes to this
number
the conditions are that it has to have
four digits and these four digits
mustn't be the same so you have to
choose
maybe three the same and one different
are all different it doesn't really
matter but you don't choose
one one one one or naught naught naught
naught so i asked you
to choose one at random and you said
nine
two one eight is your starting point
now the first thing you do with this is
to put that in the order
the the largest number first then the
next largest number
then the next largest number and then
the smallest
and then the other way around one two
eight nine i've
rearranged these digits in in the order
highest to lowest lowest to highest and
then what you do is take this
away from that and when you do that you
get two and then you carry one
nine into and i get eight five three two
now this is the new number that you put
into this machine
you arrange that in order with the
highest to lowest which it turns out to
be right straight away
and then the other way round two three
five eight
and you take one away from the other and
there we are
six one seven four so you've been really
kind to me because i've only had to go
through this
iteration twice and i get to the number
well
if i got to this number and i do it
again
i would have let me see seven six
four one i've got to get this right and
then
one four six seven
and i take this away from that and i get
back to 6174
and if i were to do that again i would
get this and then that and that and it
would go on forever the whole thing
with this procedure always converges
always
ends up with this number and when it's
got to this number it's stuck in a
perpetual loop that will always bring
you this number
any four digit numbers gonna it you
can't have one one one one
because if you rearrange that into the
other order you get
naught naught naught it doesn't work if
all the numbers
here are the same all zeros nines
whatever that would not work
but anything other than that it's going
to converge to this number
this is the one that's known as the
capricorn constant if you want to look
it up on google
that's the number that really is
associated with this work of a an indian
mathematician
who must have had more time on his hands
than anybody else if he's going to be
playing with numbers
to try and find something like this but
that's what mathematicians
do and i think it's beautiful i see
you've got some spare room on your paper
i'm going to give you another random
four digit number and let's see if it
works
gonna make this up at the top of my head
you haven't got anything on the top of
your head that's a wig isn't it
uh 2 nine
eight four two nine eight four so i have
to first put it in the order of the
numbers
and then change them around and take one
away from the other
one two i've got the capricorn number in
three goes so you just chose one at
random
and it took three goes to get to it oh
it's very appealing in
not everything has to be useful to be
appealing and fun
and this seems to be fun